that was uh man we had quite quite
quite the uh quite the meeting there
from Fed chair Jerome Powell quite the
statement from the Federal Open markets
committee the fomc uh and quite the
market reaction it has been quite a day
in the stock market welcome to Market
takes I am Dion rabone reporter for the
Wall Street Journal we are going to dive
into the fomc statement the the Powell
press conference we are going to talk
about everything Fed chair Jerome Powell
said everything he didn't say all the
things in the summary of economic
projections everything we heard about
the fomc thank you all for tuning in to
Market takes
um you know I know you could have been
anywhere in the world but you're here
with me we are not in the boss's office
anymore I got my own temporary office
we'll see how long this lasts but thanks
for tuning in uh we are here at the Wall
Street Journal headquarters down in
Midtown Manhattan and we are going to be
digging through everything that was in
this fed report we're going to talk
about the fomc decision as well as the
market reaction some stand send out
points from that summary of economic
projections I think that was the big
Market mover today
um we're also going to talk about the
biggest takeaways from Powell's press
conference because I think that was
after the summary of economic
projections move the market one way I
think Fed chair Powell moved it the
other way we're going to talk about why
that was and explain those moves and
we're going to talk about you know what
this does going forward how what we
heard from Powell and what we read from
the fomc statement changes the outlook
for the market as we move forward so we
are going to dig into all of that
starting right now so the FED raised
rates 75 basis points uh three times the
rate they normally do or 0.75 percentage
Point as we like to say here at the Wall
Street Journal that was right on the
numbers as expected you know the FED had
really guided the market towards this
reaction and that report that we got on
CPI last week I think had really moved
the needle in favor of locking in this
75 basis point increase
um the big change was the expectation
for November and for December and so
we're going to talk about that a little
bit more going forward but expectations
for September or sorry for November now
fully entrenched at 75 basis points a
three times the normal rate increase and
then another big increase in December is
expected about 50 basis points uh we're
going to talk about all of that one
thing I thought was very important from
Fed chair Jerome Powell what he said
during the press conference I said we've
just now moved into the very lower level
of what might be restrictive territory
as in you know the FED said they wanted
to get rates to restrictive territory
well Powell said we've just moved into
the very lower level of that and in my
view and in the view of the committee
there may be a way to go as in more rate
hikes higher interest rates higher costs
more expensive to borrow tighter
monetary policy fed share Pals saying
all of that could be to come the
immediate Market reaction that was a
sellout off we saw a sell-off in stocks
we saw bond yields jump higher
immediately after the statement was
released with the fed's decision and the
summary of economic projections after
that happened the market kind of chilled
out you saw stocks actually sort of pick
back up and actually go positive the
NASDAQ was even positive by over one
percent uh as Fed chair Powell was
talking then we saw that reverse again
we're going to get into all that and why
it happened I'm going to explain that in
a minute the big thing that set the
table for today was the August consumer
price index report inflation that really
changed the market thinking from okay
maybe we're going to get 50 basis points
or 75 maybe the fed's going to slow down
maybe they're going to say okay enough
we we've started to set the table for
slowing things down and really we got
just the opposite setting the table for
rates to continue higher at a faster
pace and it was all about that August
CPI report that changed Market
expectations it changed fed expectations
and I think that really set the table
for what we heard from chair Powell
today and what we saw in the summary of
Economic rejections and that fed
statement so look we did a live stream
all about that last week the day it
happened on the 13th of September go
check that out uh you can you can watch
that right now if you missed it uh check
out what we were saying we were talking
about why that changed reactions why
that changed expectations and you go
watch that you'll understand kind of how
we got to where we are today
um anyway looking past that the big
surprise I think is really there's more
to be done and that we're going to get
likely right the FED fidget pal said all
right we're not guaranteeing anything we
make decisions one meeting at a time
yada yada but given that there's only
two more uh meetings this year and the
FED summary of economic rejection says
that fed individuals or folks on the on
the FED who make the decisions see rates
Higher by about one to one and a half
percent well the only way to get higher
by one to one and a half percent if you
got two meetings is to raise rates by
one to one and a half percent so that's
what we saw in that summary of economic
projections and that's why you saw the
market kind of immediately take that
nosedive in terms of the stock market
um let's dig into that summary of
economic projections a little bit right
I want to talk about what we saw from
the rate side which was obviously that
expectation for higher rates this year
by December and you go like I said two
meetings left but also if we look at
2023 and 2024 the economic projections
aren't really in line with a Fed that
thinks there's a lot more work to do
what the summary of economic projections
told us in very simple terms was the FED
thinks that they've done most of the
work or that most the work will have
been done by the end of 2022 and in 2023
maybe rates stay around where they are
but we're going to start to move lower
because the economy is going to recover
we're not going to see a lot of job loss
and what we are going to see is
inflation start to dramatically come
down that is very much not the the tale
that the August Consumer Price Index
tale or the the Consumer Price Index in
August was telling it was telling a very
different tale than that and so it's
gonna be it's interesting to see the
fed's expectations for this upcoming
year they expect pce is only going to
rise 0.2 percentage points from their
expectations in June again the FED
predicting only 5.4 percent on CPI this
year that would be lower much lower than
where we are now we're at about six and
a half percent on pce uh only up 0.2
percent from where they predicted it to
be in 2023.
um you know pal reiterated we've got to
keep at it again invoking Fed chair Paul
volcker who whipped inflation in the
1980s uh causing the US that painful
recession fed share Powell today again
saying we're going to keep at it I'm
just like volcker that's my idol that's
my inspiration that's who I'm going to
be just like
um but when you look at the summary of
economic projections well if you're
gonna whip inflation that's likely to
cause unemployment to pick up you're
likely to see higher unemployment than
just four percent four and a half
percent uh you're likely to see uh with
very high interest rates with very high
interest rates that stay high in
unemployment picking up GDP growth
slowing down considerably and that's not
what we saw from the summary of economic
projections that tells us that the FED
expects inflation is still still going
to be transitory that it's going to come
down significantly and very fast and
that's what those summary of economic
projections is telling us
um this is a very optimistic ex set of
expectations it really is it doesn't go
by what we learned in August from that
CPI report and it suggests that the FED
really didn't see that August CPI report
as a game changer the way a lot of folks
in the market did if you saw the bond
market if you saw you know even the
stock market a significant reaction to
that August CPI report that seemed like
a game changer what we heard from the
Federal Reserve today and Fed chair
Jerome Powell was essentially we don't
see that necessarily as a game changer
um I want to talk about a note that
actually came out a little bit after the
summary of economic projections was
released from Jeffrey's Thomas Simons
and then markowska they're The Economist
over at Jeffrey's uh here's what they
write quote it is hard to believe that
the FED is capable of pulling off such a
delicate Landing of the economy onto a
gradual Glide path towards somewhat
lower growth only mildly higher
unemployment and on target inflation
again I'm quoting here here Nobel prizes
will be in order if this goal can be
achieved while avoiding a recession
basically the folks at Jeffrey's I'm
gonna translate that for you in case you
don't speak Economist they're saying we
don't believe you you need more people
uh in essence the FED is going to have
to pull a rabbit out of its hat if it
expects to actually deliver what is
proposed in its summary of economic
rejections that's big you've got a lot
of folks saying I don't know that's also
what you saw from the bond market and
I'll get into that in just a moment
big markdowns though in the summary of
economic projections for GDP for this
year only expecting 0.2 percent growth
for all of 2022. now that is a big write
down and we know that the FED tends to
have a Rosy Outlook they tend to have
those rose-colored glasses on when they
look at the economy and 0.2 probably
means zero or lower and if we have a
zero or negative growth for the year
it's going to be really hard no matter
what the unemployment rate is to say
that we are not in a recession if you
have zero percent growth really that's
negative growth um the Atlanta fed's GDP
now tracker just came out the other day
showing that they are now projecting 0.3
percent for GDP in the third quarter the
third quarter was supposed to be the
quarter that rescued us after we had
those two back-to-back negative growth
quarters in the first and second quarter
third quarter GDP was supposed to be the
thing that set it all up for a positive
growth year it looks like we're not
going to have that and the FED is
basically saying we're unlikely to have
that the other thing unemployment like I
talked about only expected to rise to
4.4 percent in 2023 and in 2024. if
you're gonna raise rates and you're
gonna keep them high if you're willing
to push the economy through a painful
recession unemployment's probably not
going to stay at 4.4 percent that shows
these very lofty expectations for the
FED even though growth is expected to
slow down maybe not quite go negative
but slow down just enough that's the
kind of magic that these Jeffries
economists are talking about that Nobel
prizes would be in order for if they can
do that the big message I think from the
chairman at his press conference
immediately following the release of the
minutes or I'm sorry immediately
following the release of the statement
was watch what I say listen to me don't
worry about what I wrote in that summary
over there don't worry about that listen
to me inflation's still our number one
priority inflation inflation inflation
that's all we care about and we're
worried about and we're going to get it
down no matter what
um
Fed chair Powell really hammered that
point home but you have to understand
that he is the guy who puts together the
report now the statement doesn't come
out without the FED chair's blessing so
we can't look through that we can't say
okay well you said that you are
committed to this so you know no matter
what that's what you're going to do but
that's what fed shirt Powell is trying
to tell us with this press conference uh
any question that came in he was like
listen listen you know my priority
number one number two number three
number four number five is getting
inflation down and we think that can
happen we think we're going to do that
we think we are in very good uh position
to do that I also want to talk about a
note I got this morning from Bank of
America uh the analyst his real name is
Thanos this is Thanos vemvajitas he is
the FX strategist at Bank of America
talking about maybe central banks are
being too Rosy in their expectations for
inflation because as we know this is all
based on inflation he says quote once
inflation increases above five percent
it can take many years to bring it back
to two percent on average remember two
percent of the fed's goal or their
target on average it takes more than 10
years the median is also 10 years going
back through history the shortest period
in recorded history as per B of A was
three years in the cases of Germany in
1992 and the Netherlands in 2001 however
Thanos cautions
in both cases inflation was much lower
than in most advanced economies today
just above five percent remember we
peaked out at 9.1 percent in June came
down to 8.5 percent in July 8.3 in
August so we were still well above that
uh assuming central banks this is back
to thanos's statement assuming central
banks still want a soft Landing they
will have to accept a much slower
convergence of inflation back to the
Target if they actually have a choice
because inflation is still surprising to
the upside just like we saw in August so
look that takes me to the market
reaction right folks with money on the
line saw what the FED said initially
when that statement came out they sold
get everything out of here we want to
get out of stocks want to get out of
bonds you saw stock prices go down bond
prices go down which meant yields went
up everyone packed into the dollar et
cetera Etc then as Fed chair Jerome
Powell kept talking they said oh okay
well maybe this won't be so bad we're
gonna buy you saw the NASDAQ rise up
more than one percent sent down the s p
up near that one percent then after
Powell kind of finished talking got
towards the end of his q a stock sold
off again and as I look out here at
wsj.com uh we ended the day at the
lowest points I think of the day yeah
lowest point of the day for all three
major indexes Dow down 1.7 s p down 1.7
percent NASDAQ down 1.8 percent so a big
sell-off because at the end of the day
the market said you know what this is
negative there are worries that maybe
the FED isn't taking this seriously
enough there are worries that maybe
they're taking it too seriously being
too aggressive uh and and really when
you get to that point no one's happy the
FED is likely to do a lot more this year
and I think that's what the market took
to heart and why you saw the the stock
market just sell off into the end of the
day because at the end of the day what
matters for stocks is much more about
tomorrow than it is next year and going
through the rest this year the fed's
projections are that it is going to keep
its foot very firmly on that brake
tightening up policy making it more
expensive to borrow money making it more
expensive for businesses to grow and
making it harder for the economy to grow
as a whole and that's why we I think are
seeing that sell-off in the stock market
and we're seeing those bond yields on
the longer side only on the longer side
tick higher or take lower excuse me you
didn't you saw short dated bond yields
two three and five year bond yields rise
actually and then you saw those longer
term bond yields the 10 and the 30 year
coming down
that suggests that there are worries
about continued higher inflation but
lower growth AKA potential recession
that's the bond market is really telling
us right now we've seen we're seeing
basically across the board everything
else lower crypto you're really seeing
ethereum taken on the on the face on the
chin uh down more than two percent the
dollar is bit again up almost or UPS up
more than one percent against the Euro
up 1.3 percent uh moving even further
towards or towards uh past parity to
where the dollar is significantly
stronger than the Euro uh you're getting
about 1 to 98 the dollar Euros trades so
that's where we are right now higher
odds is what the bond market is telling
us for inflation more risk off sentiment
more risk off trading dollar going
higher bond yields in the longer term
coming down stocks going down and this
could be a theme for a while because the
FED says they have more to do to rain
and inflation and they are going to act
and they're going to act strongly so
what do we need to watch out for going
forward
pce report that's the fed's favored
measure of inflation we know what CPI
was in August now we're going to get pce
and that could tell the FED what to do
because they didn't get that report
going into this meeting so we'll get
that on September 30th uh we will also
get a report on consumer sentiment from
the University of Michigan that final
report we're going to see how much that
CPI report affected consumer sentiment
when we get that final University of
Michigan report we will be right here on
Market takes breaking all that down for
you so make sure that you tune in to
that edition of Market takes on
September 30th uh that's going to be big
I think that's going to be a big day for
the market you want to be right here
with me on YouTube and look that's going
to do it thank you guys all so much for
tuning in to Market takes I am Dion
rabone reporter for the Wall Street
Journal we will do this again next
Friday September 30th I will be here be
here or ba
and you know I know you don't want to be
that so uh stick stick with me tune in
and we'll be there on September 30th
I'll see you then